là était l'information a été confirmée
en début d'après midi elle était
attendue gérard larcher a été une
nouvelle fois désigné président du sénat
les lui vinoy les républicains se
retrouve à la tête de la chambre aux 348
parlementaire pour la troisième fois
après une élection en 2008 et en 2014
une haute assemblée largement anat à
droite après la victoire des
républicains aux sénatoriales aimé et
gérard larcher est un homme qui fait
consensus d'après sophie primas
sénatrice l ère des yvelines c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour le sénat gérard
larcher fait l'homme etc territoire et
l'appel du territoire des line mais
comme des territoires en france dans
leur diversité
moi je suis frappé pour avoir fait
plusieurs déplacements avec lui
devriendt à la considération des élus
locaux quelle que soit leur étiquette
politique à son égard
les bleus comptent bien compris gérard
larcher vraiment un homme qui dès qu'on
prenait et c'est un homme qui est
passionné par le sénat il a consacré
déjà pas mal d'années de la vie
politique mais passionné par ce lien au
territoire est vraiment aujourd'hui
valley turquie s'est affiné c'est de
faire comprendre aux français à quel
point le pipeline est important pour ce
scrutin gérard larcher a reculé à 2
cents à 23 voix sur 348 il avait face à
lui aujourd'hui deux présidents de
groupe au sénat le socialiste didier
guillaume et la communiste
eliane assassi